[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit kaiser
richter und christian sievers
in allen guten abend wer nichts erwartet
wird nicht enttäuscht umgekehrt sind mit
größten erwartungen auch größte
enttäuschungen verbunden die ukraine
führt einen verzweifelten abwehrkampf
gegen wladimir putins invasionsarmee und
sie wünscht sich dringend mehr hilfe vom
westen noch deutlich mehr hilfe
idealerweise eine flugverbotszone die
von der nato durchgesetzt werden müsste
das klingt auf den ersten blick nach
ordnungsbehörde es ist aber mit so
erheblichen risiken verbunden dass weder
nato noch etwa die deutsche regierung
den schritt gehen wollen am ende so
deren befürchtung könnte ein
katastrophaler krieg stehen der ganz
europa erfasst viel raum also für
enttäuschte erwartungen
ich werde gleich mit petro poroschenko
dem ehemaligen präsidenten der ukraine
erst zeigt andreas künast eine
diskussion über der die große frage
steht wie ist russlands präsident zu
stoppen
zwei paar schuhe zwei hosen zwei shirts
zwei pullover das ist alles was
alexander credit mitnehmen kann aus
seinem leben in kiew auf die flucht
es muss alles in diesen kleinen koffer
passen weil die evakuierungs busse und
züge so überfüllt sind wird den leuten
nicht erlaubt viel gepäck dabei zu haben
alex hofft dass er lukas den naga der
nachbarn mit an bord nehmen darf und
dass es ihr beider zu hause noch geben
wird wenn sie eines tages zurückkommen
dann fällt der strom aus während kiew in
die 29 kriegs nacht geht bereiten die
usa die welt darauf vor dass alles noch
viel schlimmer werden kann
ich halte die gefahr für real joe biden
meint die gefahr dass russland chemische
waffen einsetzt am morgen bricht der
präsident auf zu einer serie von
gipfeltreffen mit der nato den g7 der eu
auf die niemand so verzweifelte
hoffnungen setzt setzen muss wie die
menschen im krieg
wir erwarten von all diesen gipfeln viel
stärkere entscheidungen stärkere
sanktionen als bisher gegen russland und
speziell gegen präsident putins
brieftasche
kann europa
ja diese gipfel müssen zu einer
strengeren durchsetzung der derzeitigen
sanktionen führen und in die richtung
dass russland diese invasion nicht mehr
finanzieren kann
die letzten 28 nächte hat alex mit
seinen nachbarn in diesem bunker
verbracht ein fernseher lief rund um die
uhr sie haben die nachrichten regelrecht
aufgesaugt auf rettung gehofft aus
europa auf das große auf das wichtige
deutschland hoffen sie noch
wir sehen das viel kleinere länder wie
die balken wie polen die slowakei oder
das winzige slowenien viel entschiedener
handeln als deutschland es tut
[Musik]
dass deutschland vor der ukraine gipfeln
als schwaches vielleicht schwächstes
glied des westens gilt gehört inzwischen
zur grund theorie der kriegs diplomatie
nicht die erdgaslieferungen sind das
problem sondern dass putin den erlös
verwendet um militärische ausrüstungen
um waffen zu kaufen und wie wir derzeit
sehen müssen auch dazu sollte zu
rekrutieren na ja heute nachmittag
schickt alex diese bilder aus kiew lukas
das nagetier darf mit auf den
evakuierungsplan spot von stunde zu
stunde wächst die erleichterung sie
haben inzwischen die hälfte des
fluchtwegs geschafft
petro poroschenko war mal präsident der
ukraine er ist milliardär einer der
reichsten männer des landes er ist
oppositionsführer und er will jetzt mit
kämpfen zur verteidigung seines landes
ich grüße sie nach kiew
guten abend
wie hat man sich das denn bei ihnen
jetzt ganz konkret vorzustellen wir
sehen das sehr martialisch aus im
hintergrund sind sie jetzt auch teil
einer einer militäreinheit oder geht es
vor allem um finanzielle unterstützung
bitte vergessen sie die finanzielle
hilfe im moment denn wir sind jetzt alle
gleich ich habe zweifel ob sie die
situation hier in kiew wirklich
verstehen
wir verlieren jeden tag dutzende von
zivilisten
hier ist das ukrainische bataillon der
territorialverteidigung und dieses
bataillon steht weniger als zehn
kilometer entfernt von den russischen
panzern
wir sind jetzt alle soldaten
es gibt jetzt keine präsidenten mehr mit
einem minister
liedes keine
fraktionsvorsitzenden wie mich wir sind
alle soldaten alle ukrainer und wir
kämpfen nicht nur für ukrainischen boden
wir kämpfen auch für sie wie für die
freiheit für die demokratie um den
verfolgern putin zu stoppen herr
professor sie haben gerade gesagt wir
führen diesen krieg auch für deutschland
jetzt haben sie sicherlich heute den
deutschen bundeskanzler gehört der im
bundestag gesagt hat die nato wird nicht
kriegspartei hat eine absage erteilt an
einer nato kontrollierte flugverbotszone
über der ukraine und nato
friedenstruppen können sie diese
argumentation verstehen dass er einfach
nicht möchte dass der krieg ja sich auf
ganz europa ausbreiten könnte
ich habe da eine kleine enttäuschung für
sie bereit für einige der deutschen
politiker
europa ist schon im
reifen die nato übungsplätze an sich
gegründet haben nur 20 kilometer von der
nato grenze entfernt putin es greift
kernkraftwerke in ukraine an den jugend
und die nukleare verseuchung kennt keine
grenzen und kann überall auftreten
wir bitten nicht die nato dass die nato
soldaten in die ukraine schicken die
haben die besten sollte die besten
piloten die besten kampfpiloten die
besten bediener für die dem land die
luft
wir brauchen also behalten sie ihren
neutralen status und sein sind nicht
ängstlich gegenüber putin dann wenn sie
anfangen haben david putin soweit gebe
wir es ihm erlauben und trauern 7 nicht
einverstanden dass sie dem russischen
präsidenten wirklich keinen schritt über
den weg trauen das haben wir verstanden
die frage an sie wäre jetzt wie sehen
sie denn die zukunft an wie soll es denn
weitergehen was wäre denn der weg aus
ihrer sicht jetzt richtung frieden
ich möchte sie daran erinnern dass im
jahr 2014 hat sich präsident war da
hatten präsent gute in uns angegriffen
und krieg gegen uns geführt vor acht
jahren war ukraine neutral die ukraine
hatte in der gesetzgebung nicht mal über
die nato gesprochen im jahr 2014
da konnte keiner in der ukraine etwas
glauben dass das passierte und zu sehen
dass der neutrale status putin nicht
abhält und wir können wir ihn stoppen
wir müssen eben widerstand bieten dass
er frieden macht us-sanktionen und jeden
tag wo putin weiterhin menschen tötete
der ukraine und uns angreifen müssen die
sanktionen stärker werden herr
poroschenko lassen sie uns bitte noch
über die innenpolitische situation kurz
sprechen auch wenn es vielleicht ein
bisschen komisch wirkt vor dem
hintergrund des krieges sie stehen wegen
in wegen des vorwurfes sie hätten
während ihrer regierungszeit geschäfte
mit prorussischen separatisten gemacht
in der ukraine aktuell vor gericht ihnen
wird hochverrat vorgeworfen sie mussten
ihren pass abgeben ist das jetzt durch
den krieg alles vergessen oder geht das
danach weiter
dann system die ganze welt versteht das
und sie können das immer wieder
wiederholen aber es ist ja schon klar
das war eine politisch motivierte
strafverfolgung
außerhalb des rechtsstaates
das hat aufgehört denn seit dem 24
februar leben wir in einer ganz andere
welt sie haben gerade ihren verdacht
ausdruck gegeben dass präsidentielle
hinter diesen wie sie sagen falschen
anschuldigungen gesteckt habe das ist ja
ein gewaltiger vorwurf sie haben auch
gesagt zielinski ist schwach weil er
putins schlägen nicht aushalten kann und
noch im januar hatten sie gesagt sie
lenski ist gefährlich für unser land
müssen sie sich korrigieren jetzt
putin hat uns alle korrigiert am 24
februar
ich sage es ihnen noch mal zum dritten
mal
[Musik]
sie werden nichts finden was einen keil
in unsere einheit als nation treiben wir
sind anders
ich habe meine zweifel ob sie sich das
alles wirklich vorstellen können während
sich da drüben sind und nicht hier und
ich möchte sie bei der gelegenheit
einladen bitte kommt sich hierhin seien
sie mein gast das wäre ein sehr
wichtiges symbol und wenn sie erst mal
hier sind der bern sie diese frage nicht
mehr stellen wollen
ich möchte ihnen einen persönlichen
brief schreiben um sie einzuladen
hierhin zu kommen und von hier aus zu
berichten und ich möchte die gelegenheit
nutzen um auch den bundeskanzler scholz
einzuleiten
kanzlerin merkel
eine der brillantesten diplomatinnen die
ich je getroffen habe sie hatten auch
wichtiges geleistet sie kennt putin sehr
gut und sie kann vorschläge machen wie
wir
schon schneller richtung frieden kommen
also noch einmal gewitter kommen sie zu
uns sagt petro poroschenko der ehemalige
präsident der ukraine ich danke ihnen
ganz herzlich für das gespräch
danke schön für das
gespräch habe am nachmittag
aufgezeichnet das ist in voller länge zu
sehen in der zdf mediathek
unterdessen hat präsident putins
sonderbeauftragter für internationale
organisationen seinen posten aufgegeben
und offenbar das land verlassen er wolle
auch nicht zurückkehren zitiert die
nachrichtenagentur reuters einen
vertrauten von anatoli tschubais
er ist der bislang höchstrangige die who
bislang höchstrangige persönlichkeit in
russland die seit kriegsbeginn
zurückgetreten ist die situation heute
im krieg gegen die ukraine zeigt oliver
reichert
dieses video hat das russische
verteidigungsministerium
veröffentlicht es zeigt einen
raketenangriff russlands auf eine
ukrainische luftabwehrstellung in einem
nördlichen vorort von kiew
hier wird mehrfach getroffen am morgen
schlagen raketen im schewtschenko
distrikt ein nicht weit der innenstadt
wie man sieht ein wohngebiet
es hat das dach getroffen ich war
draußen um zu rauchen als ich wieder
reingegangen bin ist es passiert die
decke ist eingestürzt
wir waren im schlaf zu ich saß im sessel
und schaute fernsehen nach der explosion
rannte ich in die küche da war schon
alles kaputt die fenster waren
zerbrochen viel rauch ich konnte nichts
mitnehmen die rannten nach 1000
mit dem heftigsten aber trifft der krieg
die küstenstadt mario pohl der
ukrainische präsident zielinski spricht
von unhaltbaren zuständen
zurzeit leben 100.000 menschen in mario
pohl unter unmenschlichen bedingungen
unter belagerung
es fehlt an wasser nahrung
medikamenten unter beschuss und
bombardierungen
es sind jetzt erneut busse unterwegs
nach mario pohl um menschen aus der
umkämpften stadt herauszubringen die
ukrainische regierung arbeitet nach wie
vor an flucht korridoren
hier die pläne für humanitäre korridore
am heutigen 23 märz 2022
es wurden neun humanitäre korridore
vereinbart in der region donetsk von
mario pohl nach aprica
die ukrainischen streitkräfte greifen
ihrerseits der netzkern das seit jahren
von prorussischen separatisten gehalten
wird raketen schlagen in der nähe der
donbass arena ein auch hier zerstörungen
die russische seite veröffentlicht auch
diese bilder diese supermodernen raketen
zielen auf ein ukrainisches waffendepot
in der stadt trifft im nordwesten der
ukraine
die folgen für deutschland hat der
bundeskanzler mit dem begriff
zeitenwende umschrieben ein großes wort
mit dem sich bereits enorme umwälzungen
ankündigen wie die genau aussehen sollen
was deutschland tun wird und auch was
nicht das war heute das beherrschende
thema in der sogenannten generaldebatte
im bundestag da geht es um den haushalt
also ums geld und klar ist bereits 1 es
wird teuer andreas huppert
die generaldebatte im deutschen
bundestag leben vom politischen diskurs
vom offen zur schau getragenen streit
und emotionen dem lautstarken
schlagabtausch
so auch heute gleich zu beginn dem motto
maske ab und auch ins wortgefecht in
keiner zeit ist den
verteidigungshaushalt so schlecht
verhandelt form in der zeit wo sie die
fdp in der regierung waren nach dem
verbal gerangel zwischen cdu und fdp
über schuld und verfehlungen im umgang
mit dem militär erneuerte friedrich merz
das angebot zur zusammenarbeit in sachen
sondervermögen bundeswehr stellte aber
auch bedingungen die ausgaben müssen so
wie sie es hier gesagt haben
investitionen in die bundeswehr sein und
für nichts anderes nur für die
bundeswehr 17 seiten umfasst die erste
rede von olaf scholz als kanzler in
einer generaldebatte darin viel über den
russischen angriffskrieg in der ukraine
über das leid der menschen und eine
klare ansage
die nato wird nicht kriegspartei da sind
wir uns mit unseren europäischen
verbündeten und den vereinigten staaten
eine last sein gebot der vernunft alles
andere wäre unverantwortlich
unverantwortlich für scholz allerdings
auch sofort alle russischen gasimporte
zu stoppen zu groß die wirtschaftlichen
folgen für deutschland
wir werden diese abhängigkeit beenden so
schnell wie das nur irgend geht
das aber von einem tag auf den anderen
zu tun hieß unser land und ganz europa
in eine rezession zu stürzen
hunderttausende arbeitsplätze werden in
gefahr ganze industriezweige stünden auf
der kippe um bürger und unternehmen von
den hohen energiekosten zu entlasten
arbeite die regierung an
maßnahmenpaketen sozial und ökologisch
verträglich dauersubventionen gerade auf
fossile energie wird es nicht geben
fiskalisch wäre so etwas nicht
durchzuhalten und ökologisch würden
völlig falsche anreize gesetzt heißt im
umkehrschluss der von der fdp geforderte
tank rabatt für alle wäre damit vom
tisch gut so findet die linke denn die
entlastungsmaßnahmen der ampel koalition
seien sowieso völlig unsozial die
haushalt ist ein segen für die
rüstungsindustrie und eine fette
rechnung für die die tagtäglich hart
dafür arbeiten müssen dass sie ihr geld
bekommen das sie planlos und teilweise
gegen ihren eigenen koalitionsvertrag
ausgeben apropos rüstung die fdp will
der ukraine weder geld noch waffen geben
dies mache deutschland partei schon
verlängere den krieg weder 500 millionen
euro noch eine milliarde euro für waffen
werden den krieg in der ukraine beenden
vielmehr wird durch diese fehlgeleitete
politik auch noch blut an den händen der
deutschen bürger kleben das darf nicht
sein eine generaldebatte im zeichen des
krieges und die frage wie muss wie soll
deutschland mit den folgen und
auswirkungen umgehen eine frage die die
debatten im bundestag noch lange prägen
wird
ja wir sind die folgen des krieges für
die deutschen abzufedern insbesondere
was die explodierenden die preise angeht
viele ideen im umlauf jetzt im moment
tagt der koalitionsausschuss und der
soll konkretes bringen unterlag guten
abend ganz so einfach scheint das ja
nicht zu sein ja es scheint auf jeden
fall schwieriger zu sein als es sich die
drei ampel parteien vorgestellt haben
denn eigentlich hätten deren
fachpolitiker schon eine einigung
herbeiführen sollen darüber wie man
schnell weg kommt von billigen
russischen rohstoffen und dabei die
kosten für verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher in grenzen hält was jetzt
vor der sitzung vorlag war ein 12
seitiges papier mit sehr vielen
vorschlägen aber auch gegenvorschläge
der drei parteien da war man sich also
offensichtlich über vieles nicht einig
ein wichtiges ziel ist wohl niedrigere
und mittlere einkommen zu entlasten und
da gibt es eine ganze reihe von
vorschlägen wie das gelingen könnte ein
beispiel ist ein kinderbonus rabatt auf
kfz steuer oder
heizkostenzuschuss das meiste soll
schnell treffsicher und befristet sein
sagte christian linden heute zu
möglichen maßnahmen und dabei eben
sozial und auch klimaverträglich so
etwas wie die quadratur des kreises und
ganz klar ist dass diese runde heute
sehr lange tragen wird denn so hören wir
man will natürlich auch mit einem
ergebnis dabei rauskommen und es soll
möglichst konkret sein wir sind sehr
gespannt ob die quadratur des kreises
gelingt er unterlag herzlichen dank nach
berlin und hier heute abend bleiben wir
noch beim thema
kernenergie preise beschäftigten ganz
europa deshalb hat die eu kommission
konkrete vorschläge für notfallmaßnahmen
gemacht so sollen die mitgliedsländer
vor jedem winter die gasspeicher füllen
außerdem könnten sie einen preis deckel
einführen und das gas gemeinsam
einkaufen um ihre marktmacht zu stärken
die kommission stellte außerdem die
weichen für eine krisen produktion in
der landwirtschaft damit könnten flächen
die eigentlich für den artenschutz brach
liegen sollen vorübergehend für den
anbau genutzt werden
deutschland will der ukraine 2000
weitere panzerfäuste liefern nach
zdf-informationen stellte das
verteidigungsministerium einen
entsprechenden antrag beim
bundessicherheitsrat auch die nato plant
weitere reaktion so kündigte
generalsekretär stoltenberg vier
weiteren gefechts einheiten an der
ostflanke an damit würde sich die zahl
verdoppeln den beschluss dafür wolle man
auf dem sondergipfel morgen fassen
schauen wir nach afghanistan wo ältere
mädchen eigentlich ab heute wieder in
die schule gehen sollten doch die
regierenden taliban zogen ihre zusage
zurück nur wenige weiterführenden
schulen öffneten für die schülerinnen
die dann meist wieder nach hause
geschickt wurden offizielle begründung
der islamisten es gebe noch keine
scharia gerechten uniformen die
entscheidung sorgte bei den betroffenen
mädchen für enttäuschung und löste
international kritik aus
in spanien müssen sich corinna
infizierte ab kommender woche nicht mehr
isolieren vorausgesetzt sie haben keine
oder nur leichte symptome auch müssen
sie sich weder beim gesundheitsamt
melden noch einen test machen auch in
großbritannien und in den niederlanden
wird infizierten nur noch empfohlen sich
zu isolieren
spanien hat eine 7 tage incident von gut
200 in deutschland liegt der wert heute
bei etwa
1734 nach dem flugzeugabsturz in china
ist einer der beiden flugschreiber
gefunden worden wahrscheinlich handelt
es sich um den sprach recorder von der
auswertung erhoffen sich die ermittler
erkenntnisse zur unglücksursache
die maschine war am montag plötzlich in
den sturzflug gegangen und abgestürzt
wahrscheinlich hat keiner der 132
insassen überlebt
der krieg gegen die ukraine stellt
gerade viele drängende fragen erstellt
gefühlt alle anderen themen hintenan
gelöst sind sie deshalb noch lange nicht
im gegenteil das gilt ganz besonders für
die klimakrise in der unser planet
steckt und deshalb muss es sorgen machen
und schlagzeilen dass sich die akte ist
viel stärker erwärmt als andere
erdregionen warum ist das so dass wollen
mehr als 100 forscherinnen und forscher
aus zwölf ländern heraus bekommen unser
zdf meteorologe ersten terry ist mit
dabei auf spitzbergen und jetzt hier bei
uns ist ein hallo wie exakt läuft denn
diese größte deutsche fluglotsen in die
arktis aber
ja drei flugzeuge fliegen gleichzeitig
und machen profile quer über die
atmosphäre hinter uns steht eine dc3
eine ein rosinenbomber tatsächlich aus
den 40er jahren umgebaut und
modernisiert
vollgestopft mit technik mit radar und
laser instrumenten und damit wären
profile erstellt und messdaten gewonnen
die dann der
wettervorhersage und auch den
klimamodellen zu gute kommt
also wir sind gespannt dann auf die
auswertung dieser daten und auf die
antworten auf all die fragen die wir
haben ich hab jetzt gerade die erwärmung
der arktis benannt auch die antarktis so
erlebt im moment beispiellose hitze
minus zwölf grad aktuell dass es 40 grad
wärmer als sonst im schnitt dort um
diese jahreszeit ist denn sowas auch bei
dir tatsächlich vor ort zu sehen zu
erleben
es gab kurz bevor ich hierher gekommen
bin tauwetter hier fünf grad plus
wirklich temperaturen die sehr groß sind
und danach hat uns hier sogar ein
sturmtief überquert sturmtief sollten
jetzt nicht so ungewöhnlich sein aber es
brachte aus südlichen breiten sehr viel
wärme methode temperaturen lagen nur
knapp unter null grad brachten natürlich
dann viel schnee mit dieser warmen luft
die hier auf die kälte trifft gibt es
dann eben viel schneefall und ansonsten
ist das hier natürlich der hotspot der
arktis mit der stärksten erwärmung 30
jahren hat sich hier die temperatur um
drei grad erhöht das sind massive
zuwächse und das was hier passiert
bleibt nicht hier also was in der arktis
passiert bleibt eben auch nicht in der
arktis das sind herzlichen dank
der blick nach vorn und viele bange
fragen beim klima den blick nach vorn
wagt auch die wirtschaft und auch sie
bank gleichzeitigkeit soll deswegen das
ukraine krieges hat das ifo institut
seine konjunkturerwartung deutlich
gesenkt demnach wächst die wirtschaft
dieses jahr nur noch zwischen 2,2 und
3,1 prozent gleichzeitig könnten die
preise um 5,1 bis 6,1 prozent steigen
das wäre die höchste neuerung rate seit
40 jahren als gründe nannten die
experten gestiegen der energie und
rohstoffpreise sowie lieferengpässe in
russland leidet die wirtschaft vor allem
wegen der sanktionen die das land ja vom
internationalen zahlungsverkehr
abkoppeln sollen und damit auch von
dringend benötigten die wiesn trotzdem
hat präsident putin heute angekündigt öl
und gas nur noch gegen rubel zu liefern
wie passt das zusammen frank bethmann in
frankfurt ja putin hat lange überlegt
sicher das land benötigt die wiesn doch
andererseits steht russland kurz vor
einem staatsbankrott der rubel zuletzt
kaum noch was wert die inflation sehr
hoch mit moskaus gegen sanktionen heute
also gas nur noch gegen rubel soll vor
allem die russische währung wieder
stabilisiert werden eine maßnahme die
umgehend griff der rubel konnte
gegenüber dem us-dollar sofort deutlich
über 9 prozent zulegen mehr noch alle
gaslieferungen nur noch in rubel das
brächte den westen gehörig in bedrängnis
so viel ruhe wie dafür nötig gibt es an
den devisenmärkten nämlich gar nicht
westliche banken wären also gezwungen
bei der russischen zentralbank
anzuklopfen aber das perverse daran ist
wird hatte top ökonomien sudoku die
russische zentralbank ist ja eigentlich
sanktioniert dadurch zwingt uns putin
somit indirekt unsere eigenen sanktionen
zu unterlaufen das ganze gewissermaßen
ein doppelter schachzug wie reagiert
denn der westen auf putins ankündigung
ja derzeit ist noch völlig unklar wie er
reagiert bundeswirtschaftsminister
habeck zufolge wollte die
bundesregierung mit ihren europäischen
partnern darüber beraten die deutsche
gaswirtschaft zeigte sich in einer
ersten stellungnahme irritiert und
überrascht zugleich
das war selbst für einen astronauten
heute ein gewöhnlicher arbeitstag an der
internationalen raumstation hat matthias
maurer einen mehrstündigen außeneinsatz
absolviert
zusammen mit einem us kollegen
reparierte er das kühlsystem der iss
tauschte eine außenkamera aus und
installierte kabel an am neuen
wissenschafts module dabei mussten sie
fast eine komplette tour um die
raumstation machen
verwunderung und anerkennung so reagiert
die tennis welt auf den rückzug von
ashley partie die weltranglisten erste
hatte in der nacht angekündigt den
tennisschläger zur seite zu legen sie
wolle nun andere träume verfolgen sagte
die australierin aus instagram die
nachricht kam überraschend schließlich
ist party erst 25 und auf dem höhepunkt
ihrer karriere
und kurz noch die lottozahlen wie immer
ohne gewähr 3 12 15 30 39 43 superzahl
ist die acht weitere gewinnzahlen auf
lotto zdf de und im zdf text auf seite
55 7
putin ist klein und gleich kalt fast wie
ein reptil das hat die damalige
us-außenministerin geschrieben vor 22
jahren bei ihrem ersten treffen mit dem
russischen präsidenten
sie hieß madeleine albright und das
zitat zeigt bereits aus welchem holz sie
war müssen wir sagen die erste frau an
der spitze des state department ist tot
eine legendäre stimme der diplomatie
verstummt in einer zeit in der
diplomatie gefordert ist wie selten
mut auch und gerade zur selbstkritik
scharfe beobachtungsgabe grandiosen
humor das bescheinigen ihr selbst ihre
kritiker madeleine albright wurde 84
jahre alt der nachruf von claudia bell
der grösste moment 1997 die vereidigung
als außenministerin in der regierung von
präsident bill clinton
albright hat die stärke und die weisheit
um sicherzustellen dass amerika die
unverzichtbare nation bleibt
sie hat die us regierung gedrängt im
balkan zu intervenieren um genozid und
ethnische säuberungen zu beenden nachdem
dies in bosnien nicht gelungen war wie
auch in ruanda hat sie sich mit aller
kraft dem kosovo für eine nato
intervention 1 setz albright dem
serbischen präsidenten milosevic einen
horror biblischen ausmaßes vor indem er
kosovos muslime auslöschen wollte aber
kosovo wurde unabhängig und milosevic
wurde wegen kriegsverbrechen vor gericht
gestellt
nie wieder wird es massaker und
massengräber geben
bei allem war ihre erfahrung als kind
vor den nazis zu flüchten und in amerika
ihren traum zu finden prägend mein leben
spiegelt sowohl die turbulenzen europas
in der mitte des letzten jahrhunderts
und die toleranz und großzügigkeit der
usa wieder
sie war hart sie war direkt sie war klug
und gewitzt saddam hussein verglich sie
mit hitler er war so erbost über ihre
verbalen attacken dass er ein gedicht
veröffentlichte indem er sie als eine
unerbittliche schlange bezeichnete sie
antwortete still mit einer branche eine
schlange die sie fortan bei jedem
treffen mit der irakischen führung trug
medien breit war das gesicht der
internationalen politik in den späten
90er jahren der zeit nach dem kalten
krieg während der nato osterweiterung
albright war auch eine große
wegbereiterin für eine neue generation
von frauen in der politik sie
unterstützte hillary clinton bei ihren
bemühungen um die präsidentschaft in
der hölle ist ein besonderer ort für
frauen die sich nicht helfen
zuletzt lehrte sie war beraterin
rednerin autorin die höchste zivile
auszeichnung die freiheitsmedaille
verliehen barack obama es habe lange
gedauert bis sie ihre stimme gefunden
habe sagte sie einst nun ist diese große
stimme verstummt
es gibt hunderte von sätzen bücher
gedanken die medien breit uns
hinterlässt sie habe die belange von
frauen zum kern amerikanische
außenpolitik gemacht sagte sie nicht
weil ich feministin war sondern weil wir
wissen eine gesellschaft ist stabiler
wenn frauen politisch und wirtschaftlich
etwas zu sagen haben
so ein bild zeigen wir ihnen heute noch
das hier war vor einer knappen stunde
der us präsident ist in brüssel gelandet
morgen ist ein tag mit gleich drei
krisengipfeln alle ergebnisse erfahren
sie natürlich bei uns
das war unsere welt an diesem mittwoch
gleich nach uns im auslandsjournal wie
putins krieg auch die russin trifft und
um 0.38 melde sich nathan glückte mit
dem heute-journal update und wir
wünschen einen schönen abend
[Musik]
guten abend das hoch über mitteleuropa
hält weiterhin durch und so müssen die
tiefs ausweichen entweder über
nordeuropa oder sie ziehen richtung
süden zu dreht sich ein kräftiges tief
über die iberischen halbinsel und bringt
dort kräftige regenfälle und unwetter
und ein weiteres tief bringt hier in der
türkei herr regenfälle es ändert sich
aber auch ein bisschen was bei uns denn
die nachttemperaturen sind längst nicht
mehr so kalt wie in den vergangenen
nächten bis auf 7 grad nur geht es
runter am niederrhein kälter wird am
alpenrand mit minus 4 grad sonst ändert
sich in der nacht wenig es bleibt
einfach sternen klar ganz selten bildet
sich mir etwas nebel oder dunst und wenn
der sich gebildet hat löst die
frühlingssonne die ihnen dann morgen
ganz schnell auf die temperaturen liegen
meist bei 15 bis 20 grad an der ostsee
sind es 14 und an der nordsee nur zehn
grad und das wiederum liegt an den
wassertemperaturen von nord und ostsee
denn wir liegen nur so bei 5 bis 7 grad
das mittelmeer ist schon deutlich milder
und die wassertemperatur des atlantiks
bei den kanarischen inseln liegt um 19
grad die kälte ist aber nicht so sehr
weit entfernt und das merken wir auch
beim temperatur und wettertrend für
berlin der nächste woche könnte es noch
mal deutlich kälter werden hier zum
monatsende sie sehen dass die
temperaturen von andy 18 auf etwa sieben
grad sinken wir bis dahin aber ändert
sich am wetter wenig im norden wird es
etwas wolkiger und kälter und am sonntag
liegen die höchsttemperaturen bei neun
bis 20 grad guten abend